bassem beaubourg alors le parlement
tunisien a donc voté le renforcement des
pouvoirs du chef du gouvernement une
première pour cette jeune démocratie
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
concrètement effectivement samantha l
etat et d ir au parlement tunisien donc
les parlementaires ont voté le
renforcement des pouvoirs lundi liesse
fanfare qui est le chef du gouvernement
tunisien
un renforcement qui va durer pendant
deux mois deux mois dans lesquelles le
chef du gouvernement va pouvoir prendre
des mesures juridiques et des mesures
politiques pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus et pour contenir ce
virus sur l'ensemble du territoire
tunisien et ce sans passer par
l'adoption où la vie était
parlementaires tunisiens
c'est un vote qui a eu lieu hier en
vidéoconférence car les parlementaires
ne se réunissent plus au sein même du
parlement tunisien pour éviter toute
propagation ou contamination c'était un
vol qui a été quasiment à la limite et
178 pour sur les 217 parlementaires
qu'il ya au sein même de cette assemblée
les réticents ont pas voulu voter pour
cette mesure ce renforcement des
pouvoirs du chef du gouvernement ils ont
peur d'une centralisation des pouvoirs
mais pour la majorité c'était une
nécessité et une urgence ou north face à
cette crise sanitaire sur l'ensemble du
territoire je vous rappelle que depuis
le début de la pandémie en tunisie on a
atteint les 553 contaminée pour 19 décès
ce qui est énorme pour les tunisiens
veulent absolument contenir cette
épidémie pour éviter que le chiffre des
décès et puis ce augmenté en tunisie
alors déjà depuis le début de la
pandémie il ya des mesures qui ont été
prises en tunisie est ce qu'elles sont
appliquées et respectées
effectivement la tunisie a pris des
mesures assez rapidement par rapport à
ses voisins du maghreb donc avec les
fermetures des frontières avec la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu
maintenant et même des contrôles qui
sont faits dans les rues des contrôles
qui sont beaucoup plus strictes donc
toute personne qui est contrôlé en
voiture sens d'une autorisation délivrée
par le ministère de l'intérieur se verra
confisqué sa carte grise et son permis
de conduire il pourra récupérer son
véhicule à la fin de cette catastrophe
sanitaire bien sûr en payant une amende
et les autorités essayent aux maximes
de prévenir la population de prévenir ce
confinement d'essayer de faire passer le
message auprès des populations
mais on peut remarquer en tunisie et
surtout à suis piste alors on se trouve
que ces règles de confinement que ces
mesures sont appliquées notamment dans
le quartier de la banlieue nord c'est la
quartier écarter un peu plus aisés ou de
classes moyennes supérieures et dans les
quartiers les plus populaires de tunis
le confinement a du mal à être respecté
les mesures en du mal a été respectée on
a pu aller s'en rendre compte en allant
notamment attendez quelques reportages
dans ces quartiers là où où la vie et
qu'on veut suit son cours dont c'est
tout à fait normal que les gens quand
ils me se rassembler les marchés sont
ouverts
donc le gouvernement peine un petit peu
à faire respecter ces règles surtout il
ya quelques jours de nombreux
rassemblements auront lieu dans ces
quartiers car le gouvernement avait
promis 200 dinars ce qui équivaut à peu
près de 80 euros pour aider les familles
les plus démunies qu'un paiement qui a
eu du mal et du retard à être mise en
place
parce qu'elle a provoqué la colère de
certains riverains qui sont descendus
dans la rue sont réunis et notamment
autour des administrations et puis du
gouvernorat de tunis pour réclamer cet
argent là donc c'était assez c'est assez
déséquilibré en tunisie mais certaines
zones dont on parle pas dans les terres
et puis est le cas comme vous l'avez
souligné des cats et des personnes de
succès rennes qui vivent en tunisie
ils sont complètement laissés à leur
sort car ils peuvent pas bénéficier des
aides du gouvernement et en même temps
ils peuvent pas travailler car tous les
commerces sont fermés
c'est les personnes notamment qui
viennent de goku le pays est afrique
subsaharienne qui travaillent dans les
restaurants dans les bars chez les
coiffeurs chez les petits les artisans
et commerçants et ils ont besoin de cet
argent là qu'arrive au jour le jour avec
11 qui gagne dans la journée dans ce qui
est un peu compliqué pour eux donc des
landes solidarité qui s'organise en
tunisie des collectes de nourriture pour
leur distribuer est effectivement
beaucoup d'associations font appel au
gouvernement pour pouvoir leur trouver
une solution merci beaucoup bassam chez
b pour tout fait préciser en direct de
tunis
merci à vous